obviamente es un delito no solo la
oposición porque no estamos hablando de
opositores que pertenezcan a partidos
políticos sino de ciudadanos que
decidieron en vez de julio manifestar
sus inquietudes su desacuerdo con el
régimen cubano es una situación
preocupante hemos documentado más de
1300 detenciones arbitrarias desde el
observatorio y también hoy están
latentes o sea están en casos
relacionados con la represión de julio
más de 240 personas esperando juicio
donde le piden penas de más de diez años
de prisión vamos a hablar de ese tiempo
un poco más adelante pero primero quiero
preguntarle una de las grandes críticas
de este informe de prisioneros de
defenderse es que también hay un récord
de juicios sumarios esos que se dan
entre 48 y 96 horas que son
procedimientos policiales y no
judiciales y que acumulan delitos de
penas de un año hay garantías para los
detenidos
obviamente no lo hay y así lo ha
declarado naciones unidas- en diversas
ocasiones el grupo de trabajo
detenciones arbitrarias porque no se
respeta el debido proceso por ejemplo
respeta la garantía que debe tener todo
acusado de contar con un abogado algunos
salen directo de la detención en una
estación de policía al tribunal muchas
veces sin abogado y muchas veces sin
saber o sin tener claro de que se le
está cruzando
y sobre lo que hablaba hace un momento
el observatorio cubano de derechos
humanos para el que usted trabaja
denunció que se pidieron penas me estaba
diciendo hasta 10 o 12 años de cárcel
para los manifestantes de las históricas
protestas del 11 de julio porque es esto
desproporcionado a todas luces
muy fuerte régimen lo que quiere es
enviar un mensaje para intimidar a la
población para que no se repitan estas
protestas y lo hace claro amenazando a
la gente con tantos años de prisión es
decir te puede costar más años de
prisión en cuba por manifestarse contra
régimen que por cometer un homicidio es
una situación lamentable y condenables